okay so I think we're we are able to
reconvene and apologies for anybody
um hanging on every word spoken in our
executive meetings this is the
reconvened Wednesday the 12th of October
executive
um apologies we just have one item left
to transact which is item 12
um delegated decision utility contract
renewal councilor Patel please I think
that feels like a bit of a build up I
hope people don't feel about that down
now it was in a report that went to the
the July meeting but because it was time
sensitive and we took took it through a
delegated decision like households the
local Authority is facing increased
utility costs due to volatile energy
markets it's usual for us to seek fixed
term prices I believe ours ends in April
23 and we've taken advice particularly
through star procurement that we now
need to take a more flexible approach to
be able to take advantage of changing
markets so we're seeking permission
through this or we've I've approved that
we enter a fully Flex approach which
allow us to track Market changes in
Energy prices
thank you councilor Patel and after all
of that it is to tell us that you have
already made a decision
any questions or comments from members
of the executive questions or comments
more widely
I will uh therefore assume that this is
noted thank you and that brings us to
the end of sorry councilor Jerome
but thanks thanks leader the last
executive meeting councilor Harding said
she would update us on the executive's
position on Ubi
um and said you would give a reply
so I'm just wondering if she'd manage to
do that
I don't know if I missed the last
executive meeting
um
foreign
from the general confusion on my part
councilor Jerome I'm going to say we
won't be doing that tonight we will take
away
um and look at what has been
um promised in previous meetings and if
we have an outstanding action we will
pick that up next time okay so we have
noted that that brings the meeting to a
close thank you